what do you think is more special
intelligence or consciousness
i think consciousness and i think that
there's um a deep connection between
these ideas they are distinct but
they're deeply connected
but
look i mean to me and to of course many
philosophers actually coined a name for
this the heart problem of consciousness
you know david chalmers and others
as a physicist i look at the world and i
see
its particles governed by physical law
we can name
them you know we've got
electrons we've got quarks that come in
various flavors and so forth we have a
list of ingredients that science has
revealed
and we have a list of laws that
seemingly govern those ingredients and
and nowhere in there is there even a
hint
that when you put those particles
together in the right way
an inner world should turn on and it's
not only that there's no hint
it's insane i mean it's ridiculous
how could it be
that a thoughtless
passionless emotionless
particle
when grouped together with compatriots
somehow can yield something so deeply
foreign to the nature of the ingredients
themselves so so answering that question
i think is among the deepest and most
difficult questions that we face
do you
think
it is in fact a really hard
problem
or
is it possible
i think you mentioned your book that
it's just like almost like a side effect
it's an emergent thing that's like oh
it's nice it's like a nice little
feature
yeah well i mean when people use the
phrase hard problem i mean they mean in
a somewhat technical sense that
it's trying to explain something
that
seems fundamentally unavailable to third
party objective
analysis
right i'm the only one that can get
inside my head and i can tell you a lot
about what's happening inside my head
right now is reflected in what i'm
saying and you can try to deduce things
about what's going on inside my head but
you don't have access to it in the way
that i do and so it seems like a
fundamentally different kind of problem
from the ones that we have successfully
dealt with over the course of centuries
in science where we look at the motion
of the moon everybody can look everybody
can measure it we look at you know the
properties of hydrogen when you shine
lasers on everybody can look at the data
and understand it and so it seems like a
fundamentally different problem in that
sense it seems like it is hard
relative to the others but
i do think ultimately that the
explanation will be as you recount i
think that a hundred years from now or
maybe it's a thousand it's hard to
predict the time scale for
developments but i think we'll get to a
place where we'll look back and kind of
smile
at
those folks in the 20th century and
before 21st century and before who
thought consciousness was so incredibly
mysterious
when the reality of it is
it's just a thing that happens when
particles come together and and however
mysterious
that feels right now
i think for instance when we start to
build conscious systems you know things
that you know you're more familiar with
than i am when we start to build these
artificial systems and those systems
report to us
i'm feeling sad i'm feeling anxious yeah
there's a world going on inside here i
think the mystery of consciousness will
just begin to evaporate well
first of all beautifully put and i agree
with you completely just the way you
said it it'll begin to evaporate
i have built
quite a few robots and have had them do
emotion
emotional type things and it's immediate
that exactly what you're saying this
kind of mystery of consciousness starts
to evaporate
that
the
kind of need to truly understand to
solve the hard problem of consciousness
like disappears because
well
i don't really care
if i understand what can solve the hard
problem of consciousness that thing sure
as heck looks conscious you know i feel
like that way when i interact with a dog
i don't need to
solve the problem of consciousness to to
be able to
interact and
richly
enjoy the experience with this other
living being obviously the same thing
with other humans i don't need to fully
understand it and there are some aspects
maybe this is a little bit too
engineering focused but there's some
aspect in which it feels like
consciousness is just a
nice trick
to help us communicate with each other
it sounds ridiculous to say but
sort of uh
the ability to experience the world is
very useful in a subjective sense it's
very useful
to put yourself in that world and to be
able to describe the experience to
others yeah it could be just a social
and the emerge obviously animals the
sort of more primitive animals might
experience consciousness in some a more
primitive way
but this kind of rich
subjective experience that we think
about as humans i think is probably
deeply coupled like language and poetry
yeah that resonates with my view as well
i mean there's a
scientist maybe you've spoken to michael
graziano from princeton yeah he um
he's developed ideas of consciousness
that look i don't think they solve the
problem but i think they do illuminate
it in an interesting way where basically
we
are not aware
of all the underlying physiochemical
processes that make our brains and our
inner worlds tick the way they do
and because of that dissociation between
sensation and the physics of it and the
chemistry of it and the biology of it it
feels like our minds and our inner
worlds are just untethered like floating
somewhere in this gray matter inside of
our heads
and the way i like to think of it is
like look you know if um if if if you're
in a dark room
right and and i had glow-in-the-dark
paint on my fingers so all you saw was
my fingers dancing around there'd be
something mysterious how how could those
fingers be doing that and then you turn
a light you realize oh there's this arm
underlying it and that's the deep
physical connection explains it all
and i think that's what we're missing
the deep physical connection between
what's happening up here and what is
responsible for it in a physical
chemical biological way and so to me
that at least gives me some
understanding of why consciousness feels
so mysterious because we are suppressing
all of the underlying
science that ultimately is responsible
for it and one day we will reveal that
more fully and i think that will help us
tether this experience to something
quite tangible in the world
you